danse
les stones sur scène même vingt ans plus
tard ça fait toujours mal
à temps
et crottes vous apprenait qui vous
attend d'eux mollement étalé sur un lit
pour une causerie intime et bien c'est
dur les changes
cela donne cela non vous venez ce mets
quoi vous allez à nice où es tu
compenses vous même vous les looks tout
contente
qu'est-ce que vous aimiez on y attend la
côte d'azur
vous avez des amis là bas
non non je croyais que vous passiez dit
m je crois il vous passiez d'eva coûts
n'ont jamais ni ils disent qu'ils ne
connaissent pas ok tant pis pour nous
par contre le public niçois ça les
intéresse comme tout leur public au
pluriel parce que les changes c'est là
qu'il se fait est décidément pas
ailleurs à paris le public sur le banc
liant un simple ils sont très fort si
jeune
jeune maman c'est mieux ou pas le public
et bah c'est différent en quoi ces
différents paraissait plus le peu plus
âgés que l'allemand le public à jeudi
par trente 30 ans peu le public allemand
le 20 25 ans comme son hayon ses plus
jeunes en elle et on s'est plus jamais
pensé pourquoi embaucher mais je crois
que à nice et sera encore plus jeune je
savais que oui on peut pas choisi votre
autre contre on dit et alors on espère
que nice et est bon alors je dis quelque
chose sans gêne que cela stimule pour
une saison elle que le dernière fois on
a pu avec la la qu'est ce qu'on dit en
français la foule un peu le problème
parce qu'il pousse que les rg de lui
dire ne veut parler de bagarres battue
ça parce que c'est profond et légendes
un bien sûr autour de retourner en ligne
en mai en particulier on vient truc
c'est que mick jagger il fait du jogging
tout le temps et on l'appelle mick
jagger
c'est vrai c'est sûr c'est pas moi c'est
vers nous pour moi c'est moi et non mais
vous faites vraiment à tout en dessous
c'est un montant de 12 août
mais lorsqu'on va pas rien d'autre que
je sais que vous aimez pas beaucoup
parlé on dit ouais ça fait 20 ans qu'ils
sont là ça commence à faire
comprenez ce que je dis là vous
commencez l'ont ils ont plus rien à b et
c
vous connaissez la critique et puis vous
avez dit que en fait votre musique avait
évolué explique aussi qu est ce que ça
voulait dire exactions que advenant du
public hexagonal spc battant les à 20
ans la musique s'accouplant tout le
monde y font la publication du format là
c'était les vélib est une évolution est
polluée
oh
à
le